hello i'm andrew from the show worth it
the show where we eat different foods at
different price points well we're not
making any new worth it right now
because it's quite difficult to travel
but we hope to be doing it again soon in
the meantime we are making some new
content based on worth it over
on this new channel about to eat i've
been recreating foods from the show to
satisfy my appetite for learning about
food and
tasting tastes i once tasted before so
in the meantime we're going to reminisce
and watch some old worth it and today
we're looking at 10 of the
least expensive foods we've ever eaten
that are all around the one dollar
price point i yearn for the day that i
can eat those 50 cent dumplings in
taiwan again
in the meantime please enjoy
oh i like the mascot
[Music]
my name is isabel i'm at foster freeze
and i've been working here for about 11
years foster's freeze is kind of like in
l.a yes it is staple right my location
here
at eager rock it's been here for about
55 years already did you grow up eating
processed freeze yes
at this one at this one disclaimer i'm
also a little bit lactose intolerant
that makes two of us
all right i like to enjoy the ice cream
though what is the most popular
thing that fosters makes i did combs we
have chocolate vanilla
and the twist 50 50 vanilla chocolate my
technique to get that little stroll on
the top once it's down
go around and you get a little twist and
then we go ahead and just
dip it in the chocolate and the ice
cream doesn't fall in it could
just keeping it upside down if i see it
coming out just pull it back up
steven is not allowed to do that i would
like to have
a half and half cone one day it's gonna
be a big day of brain freeze i don't
really get brain freezes
what my brain is too powerful for that
that's not how that works
the dipping it's like a hershey's bar
put on top of the ice cream don't break
my
chocolate dip throw not break your
gentle touch
[Applause]
that's so good that is so good i'm
usually the kind of guy i'd rather just
buy a tub of ice cream and eat it by
myself at home like an economically wise
sad person this is really taking the ice
cream to a next level here brain freeze
you have barely had any ice cream
i know i just have a weak brain i do
love how
the chocolate protects me like an edible
skin for the ice cream
compared to skin this ice cream is
actually
lighter than most ice cream i'll get but
it's still
packed with that flavor if you go to
foster's freeze vanilla is the way to go
it is more of like an old-fashioned
vanilla kind of taste
i just ate part of my napkin i didn't
eat i just took a bite off an accident
this is the most disgusting thing i've
ever seen
just doubted ready one two three
you wouldn't you're gonna get a brain
freeze i already know what's gonna
happen this is a bad idea
[Music]
how's that going that place wins
it's not over yet
it's like 40 degrees out how is it
melting so fast
hi my name is tara lazar i own tikis
how did cheeky's come to be i was
sitting in front of a computer day
trading
and i really wanted a place to eat
breakfast i'm from palm springs so
i thought let's open a breakfast place
you're kind of famous i guess for your
bacon how did the bacon flight come to
be
i like different kinds of bacon and i
didn't want to have to choose
when we do bacon flights we pick five
different flavors we change our plates
every week
this week one of the flavors is miso
butter miso has a really nice salt
content so when you make bacon
you typically need a salt and a sweet
even if it's not going to be a sweet
bacon
the other one is rosemary sugar that's
fresh rosemary and chop it up and just
put some brown sugar and salt we bake
almost all of our bacon it's like the
most even way of creating a perfect
slice of bacon yeah what is your opinion
on crispy versus
such a crispy girl how about you guys i
do prefer a little bit of a chew
i still want to fight my food all right
she wants a crispy easy too easy to
swallow
adam sometimes doesn't get fed enough
food on the show should we try to make
them something that makes them feel
special
i think so we're kind of the breakfast
expert
so okay why don't we leave that to you
okay i like that this feels like science
yeah cheers
tart but delicious bacon
time i kind of like eating a strip of
bacon with my hand
okay with that yeah i have lots of cat
scratches on my hair is that okay
you have a cat i don't but i interact
with cats frequently
i found a cat it won't be my friend
cheers cheers
i've never had bacon like this before
but that is great it's neither chewy nor
crispy it's
juicy it does taste like a warm bowl of
miso
packed into bacon that's a good
appetizer yeah let's bring out the next
one
rosemary bacon wow
crispy outside chewy inside just pockets
of fat
drooling my favorite thing is when foods
drool
because they realize how good they taste
[Music]
oh oh no that's my favorite rosemary
top three herbs easily holy crap that
was like
is it baking a bacon i've ever had i
can die happy now it's time to
take flight with the bacon flight beeler
apple cinnamon yes
miso butter rosemary sugar and a simple
smoked one
also a jalapeno this has got to be the
way to go right it's gotta be the
cheapest flight you've ever taken
oh man that's the one
oh that's so good it's like the best
jalapeno
kettle cooked potato chip i've ever had
because it's bacon you feel good
should we finish that one sure or give
it to adam
[Music]
that was an old man on the adam scale oh
man
don't say we never feed adam can i get
some of that
oh my god oh yeah i'm going
yeah all right back to l.a
in a minute
[Music]
foreign
what drink do we have here inca it's
like in chinese herbal drinks it's
supposed to be really good for you it's
just
very sugary but it's good
let's see some duck it's a dollar 25 for
this bun well for two buns we got 250.
250. all right let's see what this is
all about look at that
house made fun this is only really one
two three four five ingredients
that bun texture like i'm not even
holding a bun it's just duck hovering
between my fingers so this is your first
experience eating
baking duck not just roast duck what do
you think
i'm struggling not to eat the whole
thing it's very very delicious
little bite of the raw onion matched
with a really
fatty duck is a very well figured out
mouthful of food
very delicious i love this story about
how he was like i didn't get
he picked up as a kid yes i'm gonna be a
man of people that is the best
superhero origin story i've ever heard
what's alan's superhero name
duckman would be too easy my only
complaint
is that it was over too quick oh yes or
should i say it was over to
quack
we're seeing winston at his food truck
saraba who specializes in
belizean garifuna cuisine and we're
having his
panatas
[Music]
my name is winston miranda from sarawak
garifuna cuisine
my food is typically from hormone
culture which is the girlfriend of
people my ancestors they came from a
part of south african sierra leone and
they migrated to scene vincent i'm from
saint vincent they went to honduras from
honduras and went to
belize our food is very unique we have
one that we call the
which is like a staple food that we eat
every day
the fishermen will go to the sea and
bring the fish in and then refry it
they'll season the coconut milk and get
a flavor off of it and
add the fish to it and boil some
planting and then they will mash it so
you can get real smooth
and put it like a ball and then you eat
it with the coconut milk
the panares is a it's like an appetizer
most americans call it like
american hot pockets and he could be
eating any time of the early in the
morning
late at night midday we take the masa
and then we use the achote and believe
they call it ricardo it's a red face
and the muscle would turn from white to
red and people saw yeah he's making
authentic bananas just by the color when
people look at it you could do it with
fish you could do it with chicken
and you could do it with beans flatten
it up and then refried
it's a habanero onion sauce i can make
it spicy and i can make it non-spicy
late at night when i'm doing like clubs
and all that stuff people are drunk
so they want the hot hot one the hot
habanero sauce so
that'll wake them up saraba means wake
up
oh yeah that's what it means wake up
[Music]
the smell is a really good it kind of
smells like fritos
oh whoa is this the shape you think of
when you think of pie
when i think about pie i think autumn i
think leaves
pumpkin pie that's the classic pie i
love how the outside looks like
the crust of a really good pizza cheers
cheers
mmm it's interesting how tightly the
seafood is wrapped
it's like tightly wound around the dough
which i really like yeah and then you
just have like the fin
of crust around the outside kinda like a
fish like a stegosaurus
oh sure like a fish i want onion relish
yeah let's go
onion relish mmm
oh yeah yeah that's a snack perfect
just a nice vinegar bath going across
that thing oh
man oh yeah oh wow and a little spicy
man flavored combinations it tastes very
similar
to squeezing lime on a taco you know you
know that
super satisfying power washing videos
yeah i don't know why but i was just
reminded of those
no that that totally makes sense it's
like when a liquid is
sharp when i first opened the box i was
like
wow you get a lot of these now i'm like
should have doubled it i'm gonna do one
more
my name is amber amab this is mazadar
bakery and today we are trying our
vanilla shortbread where does the name
mazadar come from it's a word in the
urdu language to describe
the magic or the essence that makes
something special it's what draws you
in again and again and we hope that
that's what you find with our food you
fall in love with us and you come back
we were named best donut in new york
city by the new york times and last year
we were put on another new york times
list of the 10 best foods of the year so
you have all these
fantastic pastries i wonder why is it
important to still have that
shortbread at a dollar we don't want
anyone to come into the bakery and think
that they can't afford to be here
there are certain things that cost a lot
more money and it's bite-size
indulgences and that's what the shrimp
bread is does it come in a couple
different flavors
it does buttered pecan and we also do a
chocolate sauce late and what are the
defining
flavors or essence of shortbread it kind
of shatters a little bit which is really
fun
the most important thing you can't hide
behind shortbread it is what it is
totally naked so we start with the
highest quality ingredients high fat
butter
unbleached flour madagascar vanilla erin
canegi laux is our executive pastry chef
and she's going to be working with me
today to make the shortbread once we've
made the dough we run it through a
sheeter and we punch the cookies out
sprinkle sugar on them and then we put
them in a 325
degree convection oven we tend to under
bake them and then watch the last couple
of minutes
muzzleloader bakery was born of my love
of food as a child my family
traveled all over the world we'd be in
sweden and we'd have bread for breakfast
and then we'd have to close our eyes my
mom would say tell us what you taste i
would have saffron in it and i'd say god
this tastes like the rice in spain food
became a way to connect people
through flavors and experiences do you
still cover your eyes and eat food or
i do i don't cover my eyes in
restaurants but my team tells me often
that when i'm tasting something i'll
close my eyes we should do that
close our eyes in case yes thank you
cheers
[Music]
oh man it smells
like butter yeah like butter cheers
oh i can taste the butter
very present a slight hint of vanilla it
is the perfect
drink accompaniment cookie yes you can
just nibble away
not worried about getting crumbs on
yourself oh i got a lot of crumbs of
myself though i don't
do we get more i buy i have another
yeah i want another one that's what i'm
talking about this is when you get
comped at the
casino and they bring over just a tray
of chips for you
chocolate cheers
[Music]
i cannot eat with my eyes closed you
know what this tastes like when you get
a little
bite of this still crystallized cocoa
powder that's my masada
moment when i close my eyes and eat this
cookie just come in
from playing in the snow my fingers are
still a little numb i'm drinking my
cocoa
and at the end of the cup it's very
weird to watch people eat with their
eyes closed realize realizing
that now
also the smell of this cookie is a
bakery at work
if this was a cologne i would be
irresistible sure
but it will never be you could eat this
cookie
in any outfit like this cookie is
perfectly at home wearing a tuxedo after
the opera
or flip-flops and shorts on the weekend
you can take this cookie to the ball
you can take this cookie to the beach
this is my
just woke up at 1am in my boxers i don't
know i just want to eat a cookie i take
back that outfit thing
you and your boxers eating this cookie
is unacceptable to me
i'm excited before i use it sure thank
you
can i feed you no okay
[Music]
hi my name is theresa i'm the owner of
blinky's donuts in woodland hills and
i'm really happy to be here you've been
here since
2002. and is this a family business or
my uncle was baking today mom's at the
register you know my my son she won't
let go of the register
everybody's part of the team blankets
we're all a big happy family today we're
gonna have a regular glazed donuts
that's the most popular one that we sell
it's very simple we're just gonna start
with our regular yeast donut dough
mix it put in a proofer cut it proof it
again
fry and glaze without regular glazed
icing
how do your donuts differ from sort of
the mass-produced donuts in terms of
flavor
we just try to find the best ingredients
we can that's available on the market
and also make it budget-friendly so that
everybody can come in and
afford a donut at our place this is the
encyclopedia
picture of a donut let's bump donuts
it's like the inside of a croissant
that's amazing it's so
fluffy my finger just disappears inside
this thing it's a very gentle
donut eating experience this is truly
the best donut
i have ever had so the black and white
is really popular
like a glazed donut it's the same dough
fry it and then we just let it cool down
a little bit and then we put our vanilla
icing and our chocolate icing which is a
secret recipe
you're saying you use a lot of different
kinds of chocolates five different types
of chocolate we're quite picky on our
chocolate taste and we want to make sure
that our customers feel the same way
and have the best experience they call
it the black and white donut but
others call it the v or the batman or
the
it's also called the tuxedo tuxedo this
oh i like this
the icing on most donuts can be
overwhelming but actually
it adds a perfect kick to the donut it's
got that same great
base and chocolate is so rich chocolate
really is good because you only get that
streak you can really enjoy it and pick
your bites a little more it's not
overwhelmingly chocolatey i thought the
streak was weird at first but i like
that it's only covering a little bit
stephen thought it was weird
i think that's weird i'm telling ya go
ahead oh my god
i need to stop myself adam would you
like a
sample you like that yeah go ahead and
take the rest
yes
why is it important that as a company
you are roasting your own
foreign
[Music]
so what we're having is that there it is
that and that how do you say cheers in
japanese
kanpai kampai
[Music]
wow that is powerful super strong
yeah tastes like ambition bitterness
and a little bit of sweetness do you
usually go for iced coffee
always i take my beverages very slowly
iced coffee you can enjoy for a much
longer period of time than a hot cup of
coffee you also
have the dangerous game with this where
you oh i'm very familiar with missing
the straw
i don't know everybody does that that
way i also love how there's a bunch of
people here just like
doing their own work studying starting
their own company dreamers
you don't know where you're going but it
all starts
with a good cup of row
jet lag solved at least for a few hours
your mascot is one of the coolest i've
ever seen can you tell me the story
behind it
come on
[Music]
we're at the tsukiji fish market and
it's been a bucketless item for me for a
long time
did you think you'd be coming here to
eat eggs no
which is the crazy thing i got a little
souvenir while i wasn't looking
as soon as the interview cut the owner
pulled this out and just
handed to me he's like you're gonna want
this i'm jealous now
but i shouldn't be because i'm about to
eat this delicious omelette this is the
one dollar slice that you can get
a delicate golden finish to it like
creme brulee
but the size of a twinkie like butter
iritaki mash you look at mine
oh wow oh wow i actually did not expect
the flavor that came from this
the sweetness yeah but it's still savory
it's almost like
a soy honey glaze that you would get on
a chicken wing
i think the best part of this egg for me
is the texture
i'm chewing it with my tongue right
because i can get maximum flavor
almost burst a little bit yeah like
caviar it's very
juicy with the added sweetness the touch
of savoriness this is very much like a
little slice of cake
it would be fitting that eggs are such a
large component of cake
this could be dessert it could also be a
meal it's so
simple it is so simple
i want to eat this whole thing
good thing you ate the rest of it right
there what do you think about their
automation their uh system they have
here it's an assembly line but
everything's done by hand
because they're churning out the omelets
here but everyone is made by an
individual guy who's taken a lot of time
to perfect it eggs
not just for babies and old people
anymore
i like moss
so good
[Music]
what are the advantages to having the
automated systems in the restaurant
wow so excited each of these plates
is 100 yen approximately one us dollar
so we have
self-service green tea here never seen
something so excited for hot water
hot running water yeah at your table
come on sometimes my shower doesn't even
do that
come by hot
this is the optimal time it's like
enough time for you to look at it and
decide if you want it but then it's like
if you don't get it
you're not gonna get it it's like the
tinder of dining yes swipe the swipe
right all right here we have two
beautiful shrimp guys come on
maybe we should just go for it pop it
open pop it first hit here we go
oh yeah cheers
perfect oh now i'm excited now i want to
grab hey how about some tuna
i love tuna look at this long cut of
tuna
[Music]
cheers it up that's so great yeah
we can have as many as we want they just
keep coming oh you've ever been
in a lazy river yes oh my god this is
the lazy river
food but instead of you in the river the
food is in the river
you just seize the river summer it's a
pike mackerel
the fish was tender the rice was well
packed like satisfactory in all of the
ways that you want sushi to be what is
this if you get
five plates we get to play the game
oh no no what happens you lost
so if we won what would happen you get
that thai in a
in a plastic and then i want dessert
next oh fluffy ice with green tea red
bean
nice the order was hurt thank you bird
oh here it is cheers
mmm that's what you need when it's hot
outside
ice blast we're at eight plate count
nine
i touched it okay we're at the baseball
stadium i like it
yeah get toned oh we weren't really
yeah no way it's coming out
got some uh stickers so thank you for
the meal
gochiso
we're going to see miss liu in her
restaurant
we're gonna get some 50 cent pan-fried
dumplings
and we have our head of price so low and
worth it no we haven't
that is a drastic price point
you've been making dumplings for 30
years i'm just curious what you think
makes a perfect dumpling
what types of buns do you serve here
woman being the sao pai
jose jio tai chi chiang fao saudi thai
and which one is your favorite
we've heard that the dough of your buns
is very delicious what makes it so
special
with
[Music]
you know how you're actually in taiwan
how dumplings
and motor scooter sounds it's a
beautiful noise so not only are we
having dumplings but we're also
having soy milk so we notice you're
actually making your own soy milk here
can tell us about how you guys make that
one now
cheers oh
jeez i didn't know that's what soy milk
supposed to taste like
kind of like a peanut butter drink like
that's how nutty it tastes to me okay
how's the soy milk
i'm like almost done oh my goodness i
really like the soy milk this is really
good
it's like the first time i had full
fat milk oh yeah yeah you know adam try
some soy milk
yeah let's get to the buns let's get to
the buns pork
cabbage chive look at the bottom crust
it's like a little hi i'm crispy
the dough is so good what was the term
for chewie
is that an actual term yeah this is so
cute
i don't know how to describe the weight
of it but it's pleasantly plump
pleasantly plump okay the pork butt
oh whoa that's my favorite
adam you want to take a bite
you know my problem with burgers
you're playing a game of like jenga
tetris as you're biting into it
with a bun you're not losing anything
lastly the cabbage
i love the shape of this one it looks
like a clam this is 50 cents
we just ate three dollars of food by the
way
okay this one might actually be my
favorite damn it
i don't live in taiwan 50 cents i don't
even have to be hungry it's just
it would be foolish not to the pleasure
you got out of chewing
really good bro yeah oh my gosh
qq too cute i think you need to open
this in america
i can give you my dress just open up
shop next to me because i need to eat
this on my way to work please
that was a dumpling well thanks for
watching
please check out our new channel about
to eat if you haven't already
and if you have any suggestions on foods
we should try in the future
for worth it please let us know